Abby and Ben did household
chores last weekend.
Together they earned $50.
Let me underline that.
And Abby earned $10
more than Ben.
Let me underline that as well.
Abby earned $10 more than Ben.
How much did each earn?
Now, we could just go and solve
it, but it looks like
they want to ask
something else.
If you were to use the graph
above, which strategy is most
useful in helping you find the
answer to the problem?
So we don't even have
to solve for it.
They just want us to tell them
what is the best strategy for
solving the problem.
So the first choice they say,
finding an equation
for the blue line.
So let's look at this graph that
they've also given us.
So the blue line here is the
graph using the information
that Abby earned $10
more than Ben.
That's what that says.
It's written a little
bit small, but
hopefully, you can see it.
Abby earned $10 more than
Ben, which is this
information over here.
And so if you call this over
here, the B-axis for the
amount Ben earned and this is
the A-axis for the amount Abby
earned, the equation of this
line would be the amount Abby
earned is going to be $10 more
than the amount Ben earned.
So that's the equation of
that line right there.
Well, that by itself isn't going
to help you figure out
how much did each earn.
So that by itself won't
solve the problem.
Finding the red line's
y-intercept.
So let's look at the red line.
The red line C. is using the
information that Abby and Ben
earn $50 combined.
It's this information up here.
And the equation of that would
be Abby's earnings plus Ben's
earnings are equal to $50.
If you were to just find
the y-intercept there,
it's just at 50.
That's really not giving you
any information in figuring
out how much did they each
earn and actually
solving for A and B.
So B by itself won't work.
Finding the lines' point
of intersection.
Now, that's interesting
because the point of
intersection gives you-- so let
me circle that a little
bit bolder.
Let me do that in orange
and a magenta color.
So the point of intersection
right there, that gives us an
A and B value that will satisfy
both equations.
And if they're satisfying both
equations, it'll satisfy both
constraints.
So if we just eyeball it off
this chart, it looks like B is
equal to 20 and A
is equal to 30.
And if we just use these numbers
relative to this,
together they earned $50.
That works.
If Abby earns 30 and Ben earns
20, they'll earn $50.
And 30 is $10 more than 20.
So this worked.
By looking at the point of
intersection, we were able to
figure out how much Abby
and Ben earned.
So I would go with C.
We don't even have to read D,
but they say, you cannot tell
how much they earned because
there are two
lines on the graph.
No, that's complete silliness
right there.
So the choice is